russian president vladimir putin already
put 127 000 troops along a border with
ukraine
and now apparently he's moving in the
weaponry and more of them at the ukraine
border as an invasion looks more and
more likely now president biden is
considering deploying thousands of u.s
troops to eastern europe and the baltics
in response
a move that is very different from his
restrained quote unquote do not provoke
putin strategy
ukraine has now received a second
shipment of weapons from the united
states as part of defense aid and all of
this comes as biden's foreign policy
perception is still reeling
from this summer's disastrous
afghanistan exit
congressman michael mccall senator joni
ernst calling out the president's
current russia approach
we're seen as weak right now but because
of president biden
his his comments about a limited
that a limited invasion was somehow
acceptable and that nato was divided
this president has made so many
concessions with nothing in return
that's why putin smells weakness so far
with this administration we have seen a
doctrine of appeasement and that
certainly is not going to deter
president putin and russia from invading
ukraine
joey jones now fox news contributor fox
nation host retired marine bomb
technician first i just want to get your
top line thoughts
we have no war uh we have no business
going to war with russia
when we don't know if our government
would ever support our military in doing
so uh the last 20 years would argue the
most we would do is appease some faction
of our country that might want war allow
a bunch of folks to die and then have no
resolution at the end and until our
government has has shown that it has the
political will to see something through
the american people shouldn't support it
moving in that direction
joey are there tinges of what we saw
all the heartbreak all the pain the loss
of our exit from afghanistan here
you know that that pain in heartbreak
was 20 years in the making i certainly
blame president biden for how the month
of august went out but i blame pretty
much every political leader who had
something to say in a vote to cast over
the last 20 years for how the war ended
we had a little bit of a tail wagging
the dog situation where our democracy is
amazing but with every midterm and every
presidential election is an opportunity
to take the status quo turn it on its
head and campaigned on it and the
american people kind of followed that
and um and that's not how we should we
should do war in this country um and i'm
not trying to be overly critical or
overly pessimistic but you know look at
our look at the current situation right
so we're gonna put troops in other
countries
probably to to posture against russia a
day too late and also to let those other
countries know hey we'll have troops
there so they probably won't come for
you next i don't know that means we're
going to we're going to send those
troops into ukraine and fight russia but
what it what it probably means we're
sending a lot of weapons to ukraine
right and now russia's talking about
doing uh some sort of a russian-friendly
government i mean are we about to start
a proxy war a ukrainian civil war is
that really what we're about to do well
the russians represent the proxy wars
isn't any better
are denying that and you know i one of
the comparisons that that i've been
reading about is the taliban certainly
didn't care how we were pulling out they
took full advantage the terrorists who
killed our 13 americans didn't care
and perhaps putin doesn't care how we
handle it either i mean we were
scurrying trying to get our people out
of there over the weekend it it felt
eerily familiar in that sense a new york
times piece with this president biden is
considering deploying several thousand
u.s troops as well as warships and
aircraft to nato allies in the baltics
in eastern europe the move would signal
a major pivot for the biden
administration which up until recently
was taking a restrained stance on
ukraine out of fear of provoking russia
into invading in a meeting on saturday
at camp david pentagon officials
presented the president with several
options that would shift american
military assets much closer to putin's
doorstep
we're watching this in real time now and
strategy is what in this case
well here's the deal when you stand in
front of the world and say something as
stupid as a monitor incursion is okay
this is a price you have to pay
afterwards and just god forbid that
price include american blood that's how
i feel about it posturing is a military
strategy it's one that's worked well for
us
jfk probably did it best in in the most
recent years with the with the um
blockade in cuba but posturing means
that you're willing to go the next step
but hopefully smart enough to not have
to i don't know if this is posturing or
just straight reactionary we've got to
do something because that speech last
week was that bad the truth is this
isn't a 2022 problem this is multiple
years in the making i mean we saw what
happened with crimea we saw that russia
invaded georgia how we've handled
everything along the way builds up to
how this this plays out and i don't know
what russia is this is chess and i play
checkers i go out take bombs apart and
shoot the bad guy in front of me you
know i don't know how this plays out but
i can tell you as an american and a
voter uh i'm beyond frustrated look it
could spread
china now looking across the taiwan
i mean if they start to put ships in the
water if they start to do the things
that we're we're starting to hear about
right now and reporting on i mean it
isn't just about russia and that's the
point afghanistan and the way that we
handled it in such a bloody horrible end
wasn't just about us in afghanistan the
world was watching
the world i'm
i'm 35 and i'm old enough to remember
when we used to champion uh winning wars
and that was a long time ago i guess uh
now we we talk about how do we get out
of this situation and i'm okay with that
but at least i have a plan it doesn't
seem like this president has one can we
talk just a moment though about
how this is being handled and and what
effect that has
on the strategy because we know with
afghanistan the president had generals
around him and then after all the
hearings on capitol hill
he went his own way they were telling
one thing he decided to go another way
is that how that plays out i mean you
have served and you know that when the
when the call comes from on high
um you go do your job and and the
commander-in-chief goes to the generals
and we didn't do that with afghanistan
are you concerned about that happening
here
i'll tell you what i'm most concerned
about is the world didn't need to see
and quite frankly as americans we didn't
need to see a situation where we have to
grill our generals to find out that the
president wasn't telling the truth about
their own advice to see that much of our
cabinet of our leadership of the men and
women who decisively send our troops to
war for a righteous cause at that much
of odds with each other and and that's
what russia saw that's what china saw
and that's what the american people saw
wow jerry jones always great to have you
in focus thank you
thank you hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now